[Musique]
en robe blanche ou en robe rouge c'est
au printemps et dans le noir que la
belle se bouge
présentement vous êtes dans la salle de
forçage on recrit le printemps pour les
endives pour qu'ils recommencent à
produire
l'habitude c'est complètement noir c'est
une question de photosynthèse nous
devons protéger l'enzy ou la lumière
parce que elle va venir verte et
développer beaucoup d'amertume cette
étape de réveil dure environ 4 semaines
jusqu'à temps que vous ayez un endive
prête à récolter
comme ça
si l'endive craint la lumière pour nous
c'est son amertume qui nous l'a fait
craindre est-ce qu'on mange des endives
au Québec oui on mange des endives au
Québec et on voudrait en manger toute
l'année au Québec aussi c'est le plan il
y en a qui disent c'est très amer plus
qu'il n'est pas vrai ce sont des gens
qui n'en mangent pas souvent les endives
qui se viennent d'Europe sont un peu
plus amères que ceux qu'on trouve ici
dans le nord de la France et en Belgique
on la nomme chicon
chef originaire de Bruxelles on laisse
savoure comme des petits bonbons et
quand j'étais encore en Belgique dans ma
jeunesse au moins une fois par semaine
minimum minimum ça fait partie d'un
légume un peu duré comme le brocoli ici
on en trouve toujours on en trouve tout
le temps et on en a fait comme une
gloire comme les frites
les endives disponibles en épicerie sont
souvent importés de Belgique une seule
marque du Québec les divas connus depuis
longtemps que c'est encore sous ce
nom-là qu'on va les trouver
local
été seulement un producteur on a eu
quelques autres producteurs mais c'était
des petits producteurs qui fournissaient
pas les volumes pour les épiceries par
exemple
en général un chicon Brest rien d'autre
il y en a qui mettent un peu derrière
qui mettent un peu de temps moi je suis
con c'est juste du bas le chicon balle
et il y a quand même c'est plus de 90%
d'eau à la base
l'endive va bien raison de jouer les
divas elle peut se vanter d'être
dégustée de plusieurs façons cuites ou
cru
vraiment les ciselés nous en Belgique on
met la mayonnaise j'étais un peu de
ciboulette c'est rien d'autre rien
d'autre à d'autres puis on mange ça
souvent on prend ça comme salade des
deux départs et là on retrouve vraiment
le chicon comme il est sans le
travailler
sommeil à l'extérieur la belle pose
d'abord un champ sous terre comme une
carotte ça a commencé avec la semence au
mois de mai par la suite on laisse 5
mois au chat on récolte à peu près au
mois d'octobre mais est-ce que vous
récoltez c'est la racine ou dans notre
jargon la carotte dans un
elle on va aller la mettre en entrepôt
pour la gelée la mettre en dormance par
la suite on va la réveiller on va la
mettre ici en réveil en salle de réveil
pour produire l'endive
les endives du Québec coûtent 5 dollars
pour 300 g evidemment elles sont moins
chères que c'est l'importer
les chicons on va juste mettre du beurre
et après on va juste mettre les endives
dedans et on va les tourner
régulièrement
15 20 minutes une demi-heure des fois
des fois ça peut ça dépend de la chaleur
ça peut être 40 minutes aussi
pas trop capricieuse lundi se conserve
jusqu'à 2 semaines au réfrigérateur dans
son emballage c'est un procès spécial
dans le sac il faut empêcher la lumière
de pénétrer sur l'endive pour pas
qu'elle vienne verte ou qu'elle
développe l'amertume
est exposé plus longtemps à la lumière
fait qu'on voit tous les on voit les
petites faire des fleurs etc qui
commence à être plus vertes comparé à ça
celle là une journée c'est pas peut-être
deux maximum on rentre le couteau ici ça
va rentrer tout seul c'est plus vers la
fin qu'il faut aller puis là on voit que
ça une mini résistance pas beaucoup fait
que ça veut dire que c'est cuit des
alors on prend le jambon un petit peu de
béchamel dans le fond
[Musique]
là j'ai pris un Gouda
ça peut être un fromage québécois qui va
très bien faire l'affaire aussi et
combien d'endives de distribuer par
année au Québec ou annuellement je vous
parlerai peut-être de 10 15000 tonnes
peut-être
[Musique]
annuellement
ça reste quand même des plats très
rustiques mais ce sont des plats qui
sont très réconfortables lundi
[Musique]
je trouve que ça goûte réconfortant vous
avez dit
oui mais je mets au défi les gens qui
n'aiment pas leur dire
essayez essayez cette petite recette
[Musique]